so this is pretty serious because i
think the last the last uh point we
checked was 70 plus
had died so this is a serious tragedy
over 2 000 have been injured
2 000 injuries yeah the hospitals are
are full now totally
it's a shame for you know sending out
you know our thoughts to all those
people that have been harmed
today and all the for those that haven't
been following it was a massive
explosion
in beirut on one of the the port is
completely destroyed
there's a bunch of videos of slo-mo
videos man this this video is horrifying
now what's disconcerting
is whether or not this was an attack
trump says massive explosion in beirut
appears to be an attack
but local officials are still
investigating from usa today
they say trump said tuesday that u.s
military officials advised him that a
massive explosion in beirut
beirut appeared to be an attack though
he offered little detail to explain how
his administration had come to that
conclusion
this you know i got to stop i just i
hate the media so much yeah
is trump going to give you classified
information right every single step of
the way
he's like here's what the advisors have
said trump without evidence is claiming
the military told him it was an attack
shut up it's the president yeah we don't
know how he decided that they like to
forget that part of it
yeah like no no he's just trump and it's
like okay he's also the president of the
united states of america
you think that he's going to let you
know everything he knows no come on
it's it's so insane i agree i've got
i've got a couple tweets from local
journalists saying here's what may have
happened
how did the military advise shut up they
have satellites dude they can spy on
people
at least 60 people were killed and
thousands were wounded in explosion that
caused widespread damage in the lebanese
capital
trump said he had been briefed by our
great generals
and that they seem to feel that the
explosions the explosion was not an
accident
according to them they would know better
than i would but they seem to think it
was an attack trump told reporters to
the white house it was a bomb of some
kind
the blast followed a fire that broke out
in the city's port area
based on multiple videos from the scene
it looks like a terrible attack trump
said during his opening remarks
our prayers go out to all the victims
and their families he said the united
states stands ready to assist
lebanon though the cause of the
explosion has yet to be officially
determined
abbas ibrahim chief of lebanese of
lebanese general security
said it might have been caused by highly
explosive material that was stored at
the port after it was confiscated from a
ship
in a tweet on the lebanese presidential
account the the material was identified
as ammonium nitrate
citing prime minister hassan diyab as
saying it is unacceptable that a
shipment of ammonium nitrate estimated
at 2750 tons
has been present for six years in a
warehouse without taking preventative
measures
that endanger the safety of citizens so
that's that's the just here this is the
most important part is trump saying it
looks like an attack
now however he said it looks like a bomb
of some kind that may be just him
i think if he's being told by some
military generals it looks like an
attack
it could be they watched it and said it
looked like an attack maybe in the
experience of these generals
at first you know glancing of the video
a lot of people speculated that i don't
know to what degree
they they may have you know look we've
got spy satellites we've got spy drones
and all that stuff well
he specifically said based on what the
bomb looked like
the the way that the way that it
exploded and went up
well he didn't say that about it going
up but he was saying based on
looking at the bomb itself the type of
explosion
that's what they were going off of which
makes sense because it did go up it
didn't go out
so it did it did seem you know
controlled well some people were a lot
there was a lot of speculation that was
a grain silo
okay because that would cause it to go
boom straight up into the air
okay and it didn't spread out it went up
the shock wave went out and ripped
everything apart
which was crazy yeah and then because
the blast went straight up
so man there's this uh this is this guy
i'm not gonna say his name but he was
one of the guys who was praising the
riots until they came to his house
okay and then he started freaking out oh
i remember this yeah he tweeted that it
was a nuke
and when a bunch of experts were saying
stop please it's not a nuke
yeah he started telling him off he's
like nope nope looks like it's a
mushroom cloud it's like dude you have
you're you are it there were there was a
there were a bunch of experts talking
about
how it looks like it had an oxidizer
like this explosion seems to be like
this
and there's some interesting things i
want to highlight so first we have this
from b
uh bill neely nbc just just uh
basically giving us nbc confirmation of
what the uh the prime minister said
2 750 tons of ammonium nitrate left
unsecured for six years how is how is
that
how can that be real life that seems
insane to me i agreed
but so i've got some some tweets i want
to highlight this is from ahmed shihab
al-din
he says i hate speculating but trusted
sources on the ground whose homes are
destroyed
are claiming the firework storage story
in lebanese media doesn't make sense
and they had heard planes before raising
their suspicions
this was an attack on a hidden on hidden
weapons possibly
now here's the important part of this
wasn't a tech we don't know
it whatever caused explosion some people
say it may have just been a regular old
fire
fires happen man but what's interesting
is that
ahmed shab al-din tweeted this at a time
when everyone was saying it was a
fireworks explosion
it was just fireworks in a warehouse and
in one of the videos you can see popping
and sparkling
people were saying it looked like
fireworks but that could just be some
kind of you know ordinance or something
i have no idea just blowing up
we've seen a ton of videos of fireworks
factories blowing up
you see the fireworks going off when
they're blowing up yeah
so what was interesting is that he
mentions at this time when everyone was
saying with fireworks nah doesn't seem
right based on my sources
but also that trusted people on the
ground had heard planes
interesting yeah that is interesting
because maybe it's it's something more
i mean i i was looking at people have
have tagged me in different videos said
like look you can see something in the
sky
you know you know the missile dropped
and if there's one
that everyone keeps sharing and it looks
like just a bird yeah and then
i've seen i have watched almost every
single
video of this that i could find and not
one time did i see anything fall from
the sky
that that would have looked like a bomb
of any sort
i don't think that's what it was and
what's scary is how hard would it be for
someone to just make a video that
just manipulate cgi that's a good point
yep that's a good point find a video and
be like look
but i mean as it happened as it was
happening i was watching it i was
you know people were posting all these
videos
non-stop so i was watching each one as
they were popping up in my timeline
and being shared so i don't feel like
if you know if they would have it would
have been consistent i guess you know if
if it was
something from the sky it would have
been in all of the videos and since i've
seen so many
enough today like easily over 20 videos
different views from different locations
and it didn't it did not look like
something from the sky
all right well i'm going to show you
this tweet from uh ahmed al-din
shihab al-din as well and you know just
pointing out that
my understanding is both lebanon and
israel have disavowed it was an attack
okay so that could be really important
because whether it
we can assume it to be true it's coming
you know so they're both saying it
it could also be you know them being
like we do not want war
and imagine this let's say israel did
strike lebanon
taking this you know it went straight up
which which
really did minimize collateral damage
for the city fortunately i find it
interesting considering if this stuff
was just sitting in a warehouse how did
it go straight up
who knows i guess but it could just be
that lebanon said we do not want war
if word gets out you that you know
israel did this
there's no stopping the public from
demanding it and so it's better just to
have everyone be like no no no no no we
do not want war
however ahmed shah baldin says context
matters
the huge explosion in beirut this
morning follows a string of israeli
strikes on damascus syria
and a dire warning from netanyahu this
morning against hezbollah saying
we will do whatever necessary keeping in
mind i want to show you this
uh israel not behind barrett bless
sources on both sides say
at least 10 killed so this is early in
the day when they said
both sides disavow yeah now i've had a
couple people already say
you know to me that they don't think
it's it's got to be some kind of
accident
because it's out of the blue yeah i
don't know where this happened right
it's not true see people don't pay
attention to what's going on around the
world
especially when we're dealing with china
and when we're dealing with stuff here
at home but we i have the story from al
jazeera
lebanon's hezbollah accuses israel of
fabricating border clash
tensions high in northern israel days
after hezbollah fighter killed an
apparent israeli airstrike in syria
so yeah tensions have been firing up man
yep you know i'm i'm i think it's
i don't know what the right word is for
this but we're concerned about
i guess world war iii or some kind of
dramatic escalation but it's with china
not
the middle east and iran though we have
seen conflict with
you know iran the the the you know what
we had our navy ships going in the kulf
the gulf and then the iranian boats are
like zipping around and then there's
been threats like we will fire on you
so yeah maybe oh and then they built a
mock american
air air force ship and sank it
and then actually this is kind of funny
it's blocking their port of entry
so that they can't even get boats in
because it's sitting sideways
good work guys they like the sink all
the way the three stooges of war yeah
like we'll show you america now we can't
get our boats in
yeah but they got their weapons from
acme what if uh
you know trump is saying it looks like
an attack what if the us thinks it is
does it really matter what other people
say and you know if
if it is what happens if we go to war
man
i think we'd have trump for another
several terms whether people like it or
not you know
yeah because people not going to want to
change out a president during war even
with term limits that's a good point and
that's what happened in world war ii
granted we put in term limits after the
fact so you know
maybe i look the severity the scale of
this explosion
is what's crazy to me because i've i've
dealt with
news stories pertaining to israel the
middle east the conflict iran and israel
you know syria hezbollah for years now
reading news covering the stuff
and i remember we had i think it was
called like protective edge
was one of the pillar of defense these
are like two operations that israel took
against palestine
and a lot of journalists in the area or
experts in the area were telling me like
oh man
like could this be the spark of a new
intifada or like
an actual conflict that's gonna trigger
iran going up against
you know israel because they're pushing
too hard on palestine and stuff like
this
the conversations happen all the time
yeah but this explosion is something
totally different man
yeah i mean this was like people thought
right now is it feels
tense you know the the pressures between
you know
asia and you know the like australia and
everything you know even between america
and china and now we've got this going
on
i hate to say it but it's tense it may
seem like
you know oh we're all hyper focused on
china the south china sea
you know australia entering the fray
essentially yeah and the venezuela man
the story of the venezuelan navy trying
to ram that german cruise liner and then
sinking their own ship oh yeah that's
right
we have all these stories that kind of
make us think we're getting dangerously
close to war especially
china and then this happens and a lot of
people immediately feel like it came out
of nowhere
and i'm like dude it's just another
grain of sand dropped in the heap of
conflict
you know international conflict yeah
which makes me scared because all of
these things are tied together
can we can we show this oh this is
unconfirmed show it
so this this is uh i'll just show this
picture this is actually the warehouse
that uh exploded today oh yeah
so now this is another picture of what
looks like
the same door and just bags of this
uh nitrate ammonium nitrate so and and
they're just
shoved in there it doesn't even look
like i mean it says
nitro prill hd on it yeah i don't know
exactly what that is but i mean it seems
like this warehouse is just packed with
this stuff
so here let me let me show this too so
check it out here's the doors
and you can see the two different colors
on top and the lighter ground bottom and
that's what we're seeing
they're standing at the door there's the
different colors on top and there's
the lighter colors on the bottom and
gigantic bags
yeah nitropril hd it's a mining thing
like a almost like a fertilizer yep yeah
yeah okay yeah
it is it's prilled ammonium nitrate so
ammonium nitrate i think that that's
that might be it it's very speculative
right now
you know we're trying to figure out
what's going on i'm just gonna say look
there's there's there's tensions going
on right now we have the story from al
jazeera
july 28 2020 tensions high in northern
israel
clashes ahmed shihab al-din says that
there was a dire warning issued
and so for those aren't familiar he's a
he's a journalist and he worked for a
bunch of different outlets including al
jazeera
i'm not sure where he's currently
working right now but uh he's a
journalist with tons of sources on the
ground
and so i i i trust him if he's saying
his sources are telling him these things
and here's what's happening
these are important things to highlight
i hope it's not war
yeah i'm not but there is uh carlos
asweda i didn't bring up the tweet but i
have it right here and
he talks about how if you we can't show
a lot of these pictures
because they're they're pretty uh
graphic but yeah man
they're um you you see how the buildings
aren't
because the explosion went up all right
and if
it went out it would have done a lot
more damage to surrounding buildings
there wouldn't be buildings that's
correct yeah yeah exactly there had been
significant more damage to the
surrounding buildings and he's talking
about it and he goes on to explain how
he he thinks that it was actually um
pyrotechnic drones
that people could have mapped out
the inside of the warehouse and targeted
this i'll just i'm just going to read it
directly it's easier to just
read it he says you know he believes
that it's pyrotechnic drones
and surveillance drones would have
allowed a 3d digital model of the inside
of the warehouse to be constructed
using that model that would have been
possible to figure out how to deflagrate
the warheads and rocket fuel in such a
way that the blasts could be
directed basically you could shape the
blast effect
and the use of explosive vapor air fuel
explosives gives you the ability to
shape the blast effect and direct it
wherever you want
and the patents for this technology goes
all the way back to the 1960s
so this is not new technology so this
well and then you think about what
people can do with drones and fly like
tiny little drones and
he he goes and and he has another
few examples of people using drones in
specific attacks
yeah not going to talk about it but
people dying you you can well so
go look it up yourself you'd like so
look i don't know a whole lot about this
tech
you know nothing exactly neither do i
but i'll tell you this thing though
when adam brought this up to me earlier
saying that you know why is it this
blast went straight up
because i'll say this if these things
were just littered about a warehouse
wouldn't the explosion have been
perfectly outward yes exactly instead it
went straight up and the shock wave goes
outward
yeah and it left a bunch of buildings
extremely damaged but intact
yeah maybe that was maybe that was the
blast i don't know but you see all the
smoke and the fire go straight up
almost straight up so check this out
actually this is the texas city disaster
now this happened in 1947 and it's
actually a very
similar amount of ammonium nitrate so
this this was 2
200 tons of ammonium nitrate was docked
um as as cargo next to i don't remember
what port it was
i'm not seeing where it was port of
texas so yeah so it's the port of texas
and this this blew up the same whoa and
it's interesting that now this is a
quarter of a mile away this
you can see like these cars were
demolished a quarter of a mile away a
quarter of a mile
yeah wait wait look here at the bottom
you can't see it because our image is
cut off it says
parking lot one fourth of a mile 400
meters from the explosion
and these cars their paint is ripped off
the
the windows are gone yeah now it didn't
happen and now windows windows were
blown out
everywhere yeah right right but and like
wave
but it didn't look like this yeah this
this was
uh exploding out and the heat and fire
and everything with it exactly
exactly and it was less this was 1200
tons where this was 2 700 tons it could
be that a lot of the buildings around it
absorbed it
from you know going out further or so no
not at
all i was going to say people pointed
out that
they thought it was a grain silo because
of how many experts on twitter
you know verified blue checks we'll call
it that because i'm not going to pretend
like that blue check means anything at
this point right but hey to the best of
hearts
they were like it looks like a grain
silo because the blast went straight up
like something channeled the explosion
so look at look this is the buildings
next to it oh wow okay so
now that you've seen this now again we
can't we're not going to show
what happened today but you can see
cardboard boxes
yeah in the neighboring people are still
driving
that are still in okay shape they still
look like a cardboard box right
now this is from 1947 and just bl
you it just ripped that part that
building apart
so it clearly was it went straight up it
didn't go
out so it could have been an underground
storage of some sort
okay perhaps that channeled it but
ultimately here's what i think how would
they have done that though how would you
like what what explain like how what do
you mean by an underground
the way a gun works right you have a
barrel and you put explosives in it and
when you when it when it pops the blast
goes straight forward
so i know but how would they have done
that though so let's say underneath that
warehouse was a secret weapons cache an
explosives cache
in a steel you know and and concrete
structure
it blows up and it fires up like a
cannon that's why people are saying
grain silo
you know because like it would blow up
and then fire out you know
massive explosion i don't know but i'll
tell you this we can speculate as to as
to whatever we want
but there's one thing that i think is
very important when you brought up
the use of drones and directed
explosions and and air pressure and
stuff
do you think that since we created
ballistic missiles
and intercontinental ballistic missiles
we just went we're done
come on if elon musk is like i'm going
to fire a rocket
and then land that rocket and use it
again don't you think governments have
been like hmm
i wonder what we can do with explosives
right well i mean
we there was like two months ago there
was a i don't remember exactly who
was targeted but there was a someone who
was targeted out in the middle east
somewhere
and they dropped a bomb onto the car and
it wasn't an explosive
it was like an implosive or something
yeah well it i don't remember exactly it
was like it sheared the car
from the inside and with no explosion
and you just saw the car
like it just looked like that yeah yeah
so cool i could picture it in my head
but i don't remember the details at all
that's an example of like where we are
technologically what you know
it's like we're not just shooting
missiles at each other now
in the era of propagandistic warfare
because
information travels instantly all of
these countries know that they cannot
in certain circumstances have collateral
damage otherwise
they're the bad guys yep if they're
gonna do a targeted strike on like a
high-profile terrorist or you know
assassinate some you know fringe
government's you know leader or
something
whatever they're gonna do in warfare if
they take out civilians or hurt
civilians they're gonna deal with what
obama was dealing with and he was
killing civilians yeah and a lot of
people were mad about it and it made him
look like the bad guy
i mean it made him the bad guy yeah but
uh
if i i have to imagine even a lot of the
things that we've seen
when we see these missile strikes from
drones when when we see
you know apache helicopters taking out
groups that's the stuff they want you to
know about
that's the stuff they don't care that
you know about it right
just like we were talking about earlier
when trump was like we believe that it
was an attack
do you think he's gonna tell us that
like the inner details right
he knows he hasn't revealed how he how
his advisors know it was an attack
it's like right so so the the the
generals with the highest level of
security clearance
talking to the president saying this was
something you know this was an
anti-matter
maglev driven blah blah blah yeah you
know it's like things that none of the
public knows about they're not going to
come out and say it
here's what's crazy about that though
imagine they do have the ability
to you know potentially trigger
a an explosion in such a way so so so
let me put this away in the video you
can see a bunch of pops happening
yeah like little bright lights yeah
definitely what if they used
smaller explosions is that what you're
basically saying to control the larger
explosion right well
some some say that um it well there
there was an article i read that it was
a munitions and those
those popping that we saw would could
have been the warheads
yeah that blew up before the ammonia
nitrate went out the fire
the fire was burning and it was blowing
right exactly
warheads yeah the ordinance and then
then it finally reached
the other stuff but even if it did we
saw what happened in 1947 like that was
an insane explosion
knocking everything out maybe they were
secretly storing weapons underground
and it blew it up and now they're just
saying oh it was just that we had almost
3 000 tons just
unsecured for years yeah so weird
otherwise they have to admit we've been
secretly storing weapons on the port we
forgot about
listen man let me see if i could find
that article i think i think that being
munitioned go ahead i do not think it
would be an unfair assessment to say
that they're smuggling in weapons into
the port
because it makes sense because they want
to give weapons to palestine it's
important
yeah absolutely yeah where they ended up
they bring it to the port of lebanon and
they use it to smuggle it in through
tunnels through israel into palestine
underground
i'm not gonna be an expert on this stuff
though but i i did
you know i did work around a lot of
people who were and i've talked to them
a little bit so that's why i defer to
these other people on twitter yeah
but anyway the main point i was bringing
up before is
if if we want to take somebody out
and we know it's going to be all over
the press if we i i say we but if
somebody wants to take out a weapons
a secret weapons cache and they know
it's in a city
that's clever because like like we see
in palestine
the you know these these groups they
they fire rockets from schools from
hospitals that way if anyone retaliates
it's very similar to what antifa does
when they stand behind some you know fat
middle-aged mom
then when they engage in violence and
the cops you know push out of the way
they say help look they're attacking the
moms
yeah so they put this in the city i
think it's it's reasonable to suggest
one of these governments would say we
need a way to
to take out a weapons cash or you know
explosive supply depot while minimizing
collateral damage
otherwise we are going to have massive
sanctions from the rest of the world
it's going to be an international
incident
so i i found it here it was a tweet from
um i'm not going to say this correctly
but it has 19 million followers it's a
blue check marked news
middle east news um al arab
beer bia and it's they say
initial information the explosion
occurred in a hezbollah
arms store in bay report that's from al
arabiya
is that what it is can tell arabia yeah
you recognize that
is that right arabia brk verified
twitter account yeah so i mean
it's it's with almost 20 million you
know subs
or followers the the important thing is
we're in the midst of this
and we're going to get official
explanations later correct the important
thing to consider
is that depending on the circumstances
all you can really do is go with the
evidence and unfortunately the
governments aren't going to release all
the evidence
yeah so never what do you do are you
gonna you can't make things up
because i so i can't stand a lot of you
know when people have conspiracy
theories about
you know crazy things around the world
but i can say
there's you never just blindly trust
anything you hear when it comes to war
and conflict
but you can lean towards it's you know
closer to the truth than anything else
we can we can come up with
and then there needs to be some good
investigative journalism to break down
what really went on
but this this does bring up a really
good point about journalism in that
regard that we were mentioning yesterday
the betterment of society yeah would it
be better for the people of the world to
know exactly
if this was an attack or if that attack
would lead to world war three
right so there's the there's the serious
ethical conundrum and
i i would tell you i always err on the
fact that i feel like everyone should
know
that's just where i ever you ever read
or watch the movie or comic watchmen
i've seen the movie it's been a long
time so you know at the end
it turns out that the bad guy ozzy
mendias staged this fake
massive terror attack to unite all the
countries of the world
i don't remember that no so so this is
why so this is the ending the plot of
the movie
spoilers for a really really old graphic
novel is that uh the bad guy osman diaz
you think he's a hero he turns it to be
a bad guy
he orchestrates a massive fake terror
attack so that the people of the world
depending on if you're at the comic or
not we'll just call it a massive terror
attack the people of the world unite
ending the cold war and preventing
nuclear annihilation
however one of the characters rorschach
is a moral absolutist
and so upon finding out he says i'm
gonna tell everyone okay
if he does it will me it will damn the
world to nuclear annihilation
so which which is the right thing to do
in the end dr manhattan one of the
characters kills rorschach he's like you
know i have to
and then rorschach is like yup do it and
then he yells do it
and then boom he blows up remember that
scene
yeah dude brutal but uh and it's it's
it's it's a great scene because if you
knew the truth
do the people deserve to know the truth
even if the truth could end the world
and and just kill everybody
that's a scary thought you know what i
mean i mean when you when you put it
like that tim
well that's why the movie and the gravid
novel are amazing yeah
it's great top question yeah it is
and then what comes next i suppose
you know i think maybe tomorrow trump
comes out and says
it was an accident have a nice day
everybody and that'll be the end of it
but i'll tell you what man it's 20 20.
you could who how many of you had
massive
several hundred foot explosion ripping
through major city
on your bingo 2020 bingo cards because
i'm sure somebody had it on there
it's getting it's getting it's getting
spicy man yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you